My mom's dog has a kidney and bladder infection. The rife has programs for both of those when running these rife programs for dog potentially be helpful.
Yes, look, that's what I've mentioned to many of you over the years.
Another thing that has convinced me that the rife is a valuable tool.
You know, with anything, okay, isn't the right that's working?
You know, if you did a course of therapy that included the right and you, you know, you had success with that course of therapy, you start asking objective questions like, was it the right that helped you?
Was it the diet that helped me? Was it just my attitude change that helped me? Was there some sort of just emotional effect that that gave me comfort? Is that what really helped me?
And it's impossible to come to a perfect conclusion would answer it, would ask you that question like that.
But when you look at using the rife on children where there's going to have really no other effect, you know, you might usually use it like a dog or something, you're not doing anything else with it. You're not doing any other changes with them.
And you see them get better from a serious disease like cancer, it's pretty cool.
And over the years, it's had at least 15 patients saying that the rife cured their dog or cat of cancer that they were told to put the animal down, they were used to do it.
They started running a program cancer program for the dog or cat. I've had actually two doctors come to me and buy a rife for their both of them bought it for their dog and programs the right for their dog.
And so it's pretty cool when you see success like that on an animal, you know, there was no other, you know, interference.
And you know, it was the rife that did it. It's the proof that the dog got better.